this is a story about the peacemaker  actually before he becomes the  peacemaker this is christopher smith  just about to leave the military and  talking to a psychiatrist of all people  who's in charge of his psychological  review to decide whether or not he gets  into the new unit he's applied to join  smith has been  performing a kind of a function for the  us army that that is necessary but  they'd rather not admit to it  i was a very good artist i'd not worked  with him before but very dynamic very  good with action nice sense of character  good storyteller just the sort of art i  like  i did what i usually do when i write  established characters and find angles  that appeal to me rather than anything  that's come before it may come as a bit  of a surprise and yet i think when  people read it they'll understand that  it makes perfect sense but let's say  that it has to do with people being  very peaceful and very quiet indeed  you